I'm like what the heck we're in our
minds like what the [__] is gonna find
out dude that's that's right you know
this is why I think they should bring
back the hell out of kids
[Music]
uh anybody here ever uh I'm sure Bart
did um what the [__] me I'm sure I did
me why you gotta blame me right away
yeah I'm about to dude I know I'm a good
boy yeah I'm a good boy I bet you I have
sometimes I was a little bad okay do you
think you have do you think you have I'm
chatting with the fans that are watching
us live streaming right now but do you
think uh if you guys are not a part of
the patreon you don't even know but
they're watching right now as we go
bars all right um
basically to get to the [__] point a
police have alleged that a teacher wrote
a bomb threat note to blow up the junior
high school where he was teaching
sociology or social sciences man in
order to get a day off from work damn
you can't just call in sick dude some
people are so like lazy lazy yeah like
that's a lot of effort remember that
girl she she was working security and
she shut down the festival yeah oh yeah
oh that's what Chappelle uh was here
yeah that's right man people are crazy
because teachers get a substitute
teacher you just [__] tag them in
like you're [__] wrestling all right
you're in for you to get the Summers off
yeah
seriously maybe they had like really
shitty students and they were so sick of
them just call in sick you literally
just say oh I got covered and no one
really cares too you know oh yeah
nobody's even gonna question you say
yeah oh stay home stay home yeah so he
was a social studies teacher at a Junior
High School uh in Michigan that is a
[__] dick ass age though
really I don't think so you never had me
well your mom was a teacher right did
she teach you for junior high and she
taught everything but I coached uh
Symphony 8th grade basketball and I know
basketball is not the same it is I know
I know that's different but you do like
even like four through six I think is
worse and also was it just boys
basketball no I did at all it was yeah
it wasn't a co-ed team though no no no
no no you know that's what team did you
hide that's what I'm saying like when
you separate the genders at the age of
two they're killer it's a different
Dynamic how about this did any of your
[__] kids the minute they see the
[__] drug smelling dog come on campus
five dudes hop the fence we grew up in
different spots so we didn't have no
drugs smelling dogs I'm talking about
these [__] you don't know the seven
eighth graders I know let me tell you
that is true I think I was really I was
well behaved in PE and stuff like that
because I had things to do in the
classroom oh man yeah this is different
I I look back and I want to write
letters and apologize to the teachers
that I [__] [__] you have this
platform right now they're probably
scrubbed
Mr [__] ass dude that looked like
where's Waldo I'm sorry I know one time
you brought your wife to see how
menacing we were what is to observe man
he was a [__] dude he got ran over like
he brought his wife like yellow Zoo this
is a different kind of apology to watch
to watch how [__] up the students were
and then that fool changed his life and
he wanted to be a pastor instead because
I think he was like these kids need
Jesus I'm like trying to teach like math
like this will look he looked weak dude
he looked like if Mr Rogers was like 18
years old
when Mr Rogers a badass was cool I like
Mr Rogers but this guy he just he's one
of those guys that you look at him and
you're like man you're a [__] so he
kind of deserved it I like that I like
that to illustrate Mr Rogers as a weaker
person you bring him back to his Heyday
age I thought he was like a marine or
something at 18. no no no no and then um
there were just there was just one
teacher I think one was like you've had
a breakdown in the middle of the class
and he goes I just want to change ah and
then he went and he sat down and he
started like right writing um what do
you call it like grading papers and then
we were dying laughing when he did that
because he got really red like he was
cherry red when he said that and then we
were like in tears just laughing is this
in high school yeah Junior High in high
school I why but it was
it was in that like you couldn't control
well you probably good but we were so
stupid that that was the entertainment
it's just oh yeah [__] with people all
day long and I don't know um when you're
a kid with stupid ass ideas you just won
egg you know we just keeping I mean
junior high is literally the [__] around
and find out age yeah yeah and I found
out but I kept going dude yeah it's a
lot of mob mentality too if other
students and everybody's messing with
the teacher like you just start doing it
because teaching is one skill set but
like trying to Wrangle a room and get
everyone's attention and keep it that's
another I would I would assume 50 of it
is babysitting yeah yeah or to know how
to communicates a whole group of kids
like that's a whole was there any
teacher that controlled y'all see I went
to a weird school so we're all pretty
cool I had a a math teacher she was a
[__] man we hated her so bad and then
um so we would try to be as menacing as
possible
but she had this way of really making
everything so human and like less about
like at first it was so strict and Rule
heavy and then later she got me to
really like math and it got to the point
where she's like hey my husband is a
banker and I think he's like runs a bank
if you ever want an internship or have a
job you can but in the beginning I
[__] hated her so much that's tight
yeah how'd she turn it around
over time I think she I felt like like
treated like a human being like I think
it was different from like you're a
nuisance when I was to like oh I care
about you stay after you're not in
trouble I'm gonna try to help you with
this [__] that's cool so then that is a
big difference when teachers like choose
to like level with you like we had a an
algebra teacher in high school that
looked like literally she's just like an
old gray-haired fat lady that you just
didn't think was going to be fun at all
right and she wasn't fun mind you but
the thing is this time do you guys
remember better luck tomorrow yeah
dude so that happened at my high school
in Buena Park High School so it's two
guys from Sunny Hills High School and
two guys from border Park High School
based off a true story yeah it's based
off true story and they bury this guy
that they murdered her [__] in in
Buena Park which was right really close
to my house right so I remember that
movie had come out so like it was just
the only thing that everybody at our
school could talk about and then
everybody hated to go in this [__]
algebra class right but we go on this
algebra class after lunch and I remember
just asking and be like hey Miss
whatever I was like
can you tell us about like the the the
story about the kids about and then she
just leveled with us and just told us
what she knew and I shoot you not from
that moment on to the rest of the year
nobody gave her [__] wow it was just
like it was just cool to just show it to
her class because she just [__]
treated you like in a cool way once one
time yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
that's pretty [__] cool and that's
what it took for a lot of kids like
because my high school there was
different
obviously we have teachers that you knew
you could [__] with yeah and there's
other teachers you knew that you
couldn't at all they're meaning they're
super strict and then there are other
teachers that were really cool yeah like
that would you could be able to like
hang in their class and have a
conversation that would stay after class
and you'd be like oh can I ditch into
your class but yeah come here come on
and you they would let you in but then
you would like respect them as people
you know but
we don't like all our teachers though
damn you say like one of them died I
remember I had this one teacher
um her name was Mrs Leventhal and she
was one of those that need to have
[__] like
multiple glasses because it's near the
side and Far Side and probably
middle-sided too and in the way the
classroom was was uh was was like set up
here's the chalkboard and here's all
these rows of like the the desks that
are connected to the chairs and then I
remember I would like sit back there I'm
like hey Miss levinthal and it should
like turn around and it's just like
switch Graphics like what what and then
she's like
like go back to writing on the
chalkboard and I'll be on that side
she's like
because you brought that up and I was
like oh were the other students like
laughing their ass off watching you do
that [__] no it was actually a smart
class you know Model United Nations like
it's like a debate thing yeah so it was
probably like 90 smart kids that hated
my guts because I'm ruining the learning
and then there was like me and like a
couple of other delinquent kids that
were just like having a good time how
did you get in that special class you
had good grades no I don't even know
they just put me in there I didn't last
very long I feel like that's just
innocent though that's fun yeah we did a
little like innocent things so I went to
a super small school you know we had fun
and I didn't go as crazy as the others
because my mom taught there for like 30
years so all the teachers knew
everything about me and so and I knew
them so I knew how far I could go with
each one so I never really got in
trouble but I [__] with them a lot some
of my homies go a little crazy and we
had one science teacher man I'm sorry
bro and they they went up in class and
he just had like weird quirks I don't
know if he had like Tourette's or what
you know just some weird [__] and homies
uh went up while he's riding on the
board somehow slipped his cell phone out
of his pocket oh [__] just went back to
our desk they called themselves to get
his cell phone number and then like
called them for the next like eight
years even in college even in college
they'd be calling them at like 2 A.M but
that's like innocent
three years out of high school they
thought it was so funny they'd be
calling them you know what sucks about
being the teacher what sucks about being
the teacher it's like your first time
doing stand-up comedy but all the
hecklers are professional that's true it
is [__] dude dude that's rough you
just want to like teach the periodic
table and then you have [__] like us
every single time you turn around we
Chuck [__] at you it hit you on the back
of the head or whatever right I'm like
what the hell we're in our minds like
what the [__] is [__] around to find out
dude that's that's you know this is why
I think they should bring back beating
the hell out of kids
bring back beating the hell out of kids
because they used to have a paddle
remember that yeah and I remember I
think it was elementary school when they
stopped
um hitting or something or whatever yeah
but then my brother got it so that
generation they all got it but I'm like
man I kind of needed that [__] like
seriously I didn't dude I wasn't afraid
of any teacher or any punishment it's so
nice when you can figure out which
teacher you can actually mess with and
they can take it
I did that to this one uh science
teacher because he had some for some
reason he had a giant Bugs Bunny Doll
like a carnival one that you would win
it's huge and he had it like tied to the
corner of the ceiling and it was just
like diagonally looking down and one day
I found a bunch of clay in the lab and I
made like a dick out of the clay and I
put it on the bug's bunny thing I tied
it to it and then I got it Oreos I took
all the white stuff off and I covered
the dick with all that white wow so
creative and then like that [__]
had respect for you that it is a
difference but it went several days with
him not knowing and the whole class
would just be laughing looking because
it's behind him so everyone should be
laughing at it and then like one day he
he's like uh oh Ryan I need to see my
office after class I was like oh [__]
someone ratted on you yeah and then and
then he's he's playing up this like like
I'm in big big trouble and he just goes
Aegis tell me what that white shoe was
I couldn't figure out what that was but
I know that's my clay he's like but
what's that white [__] and I was like
you're so cool bro
it's Oreo
[Music]